une grande première à trappes la ville a
organisé ce dimanche 15 avril son tout
premier semi marathon a rendez-vous dans
les cartons depuis de nombreux mois
on a on avait un besoin un amant qui
existait sur cette ville c'est que les
trappistes couraient tous
individuellement mais ne se retrouver
jamais ensemble pour une course unique
donc on a choisi d'organiser cette année
elle répond à un vrai besoin
ce dimanche ils étaient 168 inscrits au
départ les coureurs en débuté par deux
kilomètres en zone urbaine avant de
s'engouffrer dans l'île de loisirs un
secteur qui représentait 80% du parcours
on profite vraiment un cadre
exceptionnel avec lille de loisirs
beaucoup de coureurs spontanément
attrapé dans les environs viennent
courir sur l'île de loisirs donc ils
connaissent le cadre est franchement
profiter du bruit des oiseaux de la
musique de l'île de loisirs qui si
singulière de l'aspect nature de cette
course c'est un bénéfice dont on va
profiter à fond sur la ligne d'arrivée
younès il del modène du club d'evreux a
emporté cette première épreuve le
coureur a dompté les 21 km du parcours
en 1h 10 minutes et 27 secondes
en plus de beaucoup de la forêt a pas de
coups de la rue tu lui as d'où vont
aussi mais moi j'étais à lisa le premier
10 km mais après un second long métrage
et du corps mais j'ai fini
tranquille et j'ai gagné vu le succès
rencontré cette année une nouvelle
édition devrait être à nouveau organisé
sur trappe en 2019